à paris les sites les plus emblématiques
ont été pris d'assaut par les parisiens
aussi par les touristes
ainsi la tour eiffel a offert un
spectacle digne d'une carte postale
malgré les nuages qui planaient au
dessus de la dame de fer olivier caroff
et mathieu dreujou 12 heures 22 minutes
50 secondes exactement
l'éclipsé est à son maximum au dessus de
paris
le monde s'est arrêté depuis quelques
minutes au pied de la tour eiffel
personne ou presque pour regarder le
bâtiment le plus célèbre de la capitale
sur le champ de mars des touristes bien
sûr mais aussi quelques vétérans de
l'éclipsé partielle de 61 ans qui était
disparu car ce spectacle certains
hésitaient pourtant à venir le voir un
peu de snobisme peut-être mais la
curiosité l'a emporté ah non moi je ne
voulais pas y aller comme chose est en
fait au contraire plus était médiatisée
moi j'avais envie d'y aller et je
sentais que mon mari avait envie d'y
aller nos amis aussi donc voilà je suis
très contente d'être venue
j'avais jamais vu des clipse il est plus
que temps
même les indifférents ce que les clips
qui n'empêchera jamais dormir avaient
fait le déplacement
après la tour eiffel montons sur la
butte